WHAT APPEARED TO BE A HASTILY
ORGANIZED NEWS CONFERENCE, THE
DIRECTOR OF NATIONAL
INTELLIGENCE JOHN RATCLIFFE
ANNOUNCED BREAKING NEWS ON
ELECTION INTERFERENCE, U.S.
INTELLIGENCE HAS LEARNED THAT
IRAN AND RUSSIA HAVE OBTAINED
SOME U.S. VOTER REGISTRATION
INFORMATION, HE SAID THERE’S
EVIDENCE IRAN SENT FAKE EMAILS
MIMICKING CONSERVATIVE GROUPS TO
INTIMIDATE VOTERS AND DAMAGE THE
SITTING PRESIDENT, AS PART OF
WHAT HE SAID, THERE WAS MORE --
WHAT DID HE SAY, WHAT WE
BELIEVE?
WE ARE STILL SORTING IT OUT, A
FULL REPORT ON THAT IS JUST A
MINUTE OR TWO FROM NOW.
AS YOU CAN TELL, EVEN BY THE
STANDARDS OF A LATE OCTOBER
THURSDAY IN A PRESIDENTIAL YEAR,
THERE’S AN AWFUL LOT GOING ON.
IN A NORMAL YEAR, THAT WOULD BE
CONSIDERED A BIG DEAL,
PRESIDENTIAL DEBATES GIVE VOTERS
CRITICAL INFORMATION ABOUT THE
CANDIDATES IN THE DAYS BEFORE AN
ELECTION.
THEY USED TO BE CONSIDERED A
GOOD THING, AN ESSENTIAL PART OF
OUR CIVIC LIFE BUT IT’S NOT
ANYMORE.
THIS YEAR THE DEBATE COMMISSION
HAS
HAS DECIDED TO CUT THE
PARTICIPANTS MICROPHONE IF THEY
TALK TOO MUCH, YOU WON’T BE ABLE
TO HEAR THE PEOPLE YOU’RE
SUPPOSED TO BE BOARDING FOR IN A
WEEK AND A HALF WHEN THEY SPEAK.
THAT’S AN ODD DECISION BUT IN A
WAY IT MAKES PERFECT SENSE GIVEN
THE MOMENT.
IF THERE’S A UNIFYING THEME ON
THE LEFT OR RIGHT NOW IT’S THAT
MORE INFORMATION IS BAD.
SCARY.
VOTERS SHOULD KNOW TOO MUCH,
THEY HAVE NO RIGHT TO KNOW.
STOP WITH YOUR IMPERIOUS
QUESTIONS ABOUT WHAT’S HAPPENING
AROUND YOU, QUESTIONS ABOUT
GEORGE SOROS ARE MANDATORY FLU
VACCINES OR BLM LONG-TERM AGENDA
FOR YOUR CHILDREN, AND ABOVE
ALL, PLEASE SHUT UP ABOUT
HUNDRED BIDEN’S LAPTOP -- NOT
ANOTHER WORD ABOUT THAT.
THIS IS NOT A SUGGESTION BY THE
WAY, IT’S AN ORDER AND IT HAS
BEEN DELIVERED BY THE MOST
POWERFUL PEOPLE IN THE WORLD.
SILICON VALLEY BILLIONAIRES, THE
FEDERAL SPY AGENCIES, EVEN BORAT
HIMSELF.
EVERYONE OF THEM WISER AND MUCH
RICHER THAN YOU ARE WOULD LIKE
YOU TO KNOW THERE IS NO REASON
TO ASK A SINGLE QUESTION ABOUT
THE DOCUMENTS ON HUNTER BIDEN’S
COMPUTER AND THERE ARE COUNTLESS
REASONS NOT TO ASK.
FOR STARTERS, IT’S ALL RUSSIAN
DISINFORMATION, PLANTED BY
VLADIMIR PUTIN HIMSELF TO
DISCREDIT WASHINGTON LOBBYISTS
WHO HONESTLY HAVE DONE NOTHING
WRONG.
THE DOCUMENTS ARE ALSO "HACKED
MATERIAL."
, NOT ONLY ARE THEY FAKE A MONTH
SOMEONE STOLE THEM.
YOU WANT TO BE PART OF THE
THEFT?
DIDN’T THINK SO.
AND WHILE YOU’RE AT IT, YOU
SHOULD ALSO KNOW RUDY GIULIANI
COULD VERY WELL BE A
SEX OFFENDER THAT MEANS HUNTER
BIDEN’S EMAILS CANNOT BE REAL.
I STARTED TO GET THE PICTURE
HERE?
NORMAL QUESTIONS AMERICA,
CURIOSITY KILLED THE CAT IF YOU
KNOW WHAT WE ARE SAYING.
IF YOU CARE TO KEEP YOUR
SOCIAL MEDIA PRIVILEGES, YOU
WON’T SAY A WORD ABOUT THE
LAPTOP, JUST AS
"THE NEW YORK POST" WHAT HAPPENS
WHEN YOU GET UPPITY AND START TO
THINK THE FIRST AMENDMENT IS
REAL.
THAT’S WHERE WE ARE RIGHT NOW
OCTOBER 21ST 2020, IT WILL ALL
BE AMAZING.
IT’S INSTRUCTIVE TOO, WHAT WE
REALLY LEARNED IS THE CLASS
SYSTEM IN THIS COUNTRY IS REAL,
MORE REAL THAN WE EVER KNEW.
IF YOU’RE AT THE MEMBER OF THE
GROUP IN CHARGE RIGHT NOW,
JEFFREY EPSTEIN UNDERSTOOD THAT
EARLY ON.
WHEN YOU’RE ON THE RIGHT TEAM,
YOU CAN PUBLISH SOMEONE ELSE’S
TAX RETURNS OR PRIVATE PHONE
CALLS AND NO QUESTIONS WILL BE
ASKED.
IS THAT LEGAL?
WHO CARES?
YOU CAN BROADCAST YOUR FETISH
LIVE ON A ZOOM CALL AND KEEP
YOUR LIFE ON CNN -- YOU’RE TOO
IMPORTANT TO FIRE.
THOSE OF THE NEW RULES.
IF YOU’RE ON THE WRONG TEAM AND
MANY ARE, IT CAN BE FRUSTRATING
TO WATCH ALL OF THIS.
IF YOU DARED TO BEHAVE LIKE
THESE PEOPLE BEHAVED, YOU WOULD
BE IN TROUBLE.
ACTUALLY THERE IS HOPE BECAUSE
PEOPLE THIS AWFUL CANNOT RULE
THIS COUNTRY FOREVER, THEY
AREN’T CAPABLE OF IT.
THEY ARE TOO ARROGANT AND TOO
STUPID.
STUPID ENOUGH TO LET THEIR
HYPOCRISY SHOW, YOU CANNOT
IMPOSE RULES REFUSED TO FOLLOW,
IT’S TOO INFURIATING.
TONIGHT WE’VE GOT AN AMAZING
EXAMPLE OF THIS, IT’S WORTH
PUTTING ON THE MUSEUM OF
HYPOCRISY -- THIS IS A GOOD ONE.
CHRIS CUOMO, PRIME TIME ANCHOR
ON CNN, BROTHER OF A SITTING
GOVERNOR, BEFORE WE TELL YOU THE
STORY, SOME CONTEXT -- THE ONE
THING YOU ARE LIKELY TO KNOW
ABOUT CHRIS CUOMO ABOUT THE
OBVIOUS, HE REALLY BELIEVES IN
MASKS.
AND REALLY BELIEVES SINCERE
RELIGIOUS INTENSITY.
IF THERE WAS A SHRINE TO THE
PATRON SAINT OF PAPER SURGICAL
MASKS SOMEWHERE IN PORTUGAL,
CHRIS CUOMO WOULD GO THERE EACH
SUMMER, HE WOULD CRAWL ON HIS
KNEES IF HE HAD TO -- SUCH AS
HIS DEVOTION.
HERE IS CHRIS CUOMO.
>> HOW DO WE HELP -- PUT ON THE
MASK.
IF YOU’RE IN CALIFORNIA IN
RIVERSIDE, WHERE THE MASK.
IF YOU WANT TO AVOID SITUATIONS
LIKE THIS WHERE YOU LIVE, WHERE
THE MASK.
IF WE CARE ABOUT DOING THE RIGHT
THING -- I WEAR THE MASK FOR YOU
AS MUCH AS I DO IT FOR ME.
YOU NEED TO WEAR A MASK AND YOU
HAVE TO TAKE CARE OF PEOPLE IN
YOUR COMMUNITY.
IT’S ME WHEN I WEAR A MASK FOR
YOU AS MUCH AS I WEAR IT FOR ME.
CHEW ON THAT FOR A MINUTE, IT’S
A POWERFUL STATEMENT IF YOU
THINK ABOUT IT.
IT’S DEEP.
THIS MAN IS SUFFERING FOR US AND
FOR OUR SAKE AND ALL ON A CABLE
NEWS SALARY.
THERE’S SOMETHING HOLY ABOUT IT.
THE QUESTION IS IS IT REAL, IS
THIS MAN ACTUALLY DIETRICH
BONHOEFFER OR IS HE JIMMY
SWAGGART.
IT’S CLEAR WITH HIS BUILDING
SUPERINTENDENT THINKS, THIS SHOW
HAS OBTAINED A LETTER FROM THE
MANAGEMENT OF THE NEW YORK CITY
APARTMENT BUILDING, THE LETTER
IS ADDRESS DIRECTLY TO CHRIS
CUOMO, THE DATE IS AUGUST 62020.
"DEAR MR. CUOMO, I’M SURE AS YOU
KNOW BECAUSE OF THE ONGOING
COVID-19 HEALTH CRISIS, ON APRIL
ISSUED EXECUTIVE ORDER WHICH
ORDERS ANYONE OVER THE AGE OF
TWO TO WEAR A MASK THAT COVER
THEIR MOUTH AND NOSE IN A PUBLIC
SPACE.
"IT’S FAIR THAT HE WOULD KNOW
THAT, BECAUSE HE’S THE MASK GUY.
WITH THAT IN MIND, LISTEN TO HOW
THE LETTER CONTINUOUS.
"YOU HAVE BEEN OBSERVED ENTERING
AND EXITING THE BUILDING AND
RIDING THE ELEVATOR WITHOUT THE
REQUIRED FACE COVERINGS.
EVEN THOUGH STAFF MEMBERS HAVE
ASKED YOU TO COMPLY WITH THIS
REQUIREMENT, YOU HAVE REFUSED TO
DO SO.
THIS IS A VIOLATION OF THE
EXECUTIVE ORDER, BUILDING
POLICY, AND IT PLACES OTHER
RESIDENTS AND OUR STAFF AT RISK.
THERE ARE NO EXCEPTIONS TO THIS
RULE AND WHO ARE REQUIRED TO
COMPLY."
THE LETTER GOES ON TO THREATEN
CHRIS CUOMO WITH A $500 FINE IF
HE CONTINUES TO ENDANGER HIS
NEIGHBORS AND THE CITY WITH HIS
MASSLESS IN THE SPIRIT OF THAT’S
WITH THE LETTER SAYS.
LET THAT SINK IN FOR A MOMENT.
AT THIS POINT WE CAN GUESS WHAT
YOU’RE THINKING, THIS HAS GOT TO
BE RUSSIAN DISINFORMATION.
VLADIMIR PUTIN HATES MASKS,
OBVIOUSLY, HE’S VLADIMIR PUTIN,
HE’S BAD.
BAD PEOPLE DON’T LIKE MASKS,
THAT’S SIMPLE.
HE WOULD LIKE NOTHING MORE IN
THE WORLD THAN TO DISCREDIT
CHRIS CUOMO BECAUSE CHRIS CUOMO
IS THIS COUNTRY’S FOREMOST AND
FEARLESS DEFENDER OF MASK NESTS.
THAT’S WHAT WE ASSUME IS GOING
ON BUT THEN WE DID SOME
REPORTING.
IN SHORT ORDER, IT PAINS US TO
TELL YOU BUT WE HAVE TO, THIS
SHOW HAS CONFIRMED THE LETTER IS
IN FACT REAL, IT’S NOT A RUSSIAN
PLANT.
WE CALL THE BUILDING MANAGER AND
SHE SPOKE PERFECT ENGLISH, NOT A
HINT OF SLAVIC INFLECTION.
SHE ADMITTED TO WRITING THE
LETTER.
WE SHOULD TELL YOU SHE BECAME
UPSET WHEN WE MENTIONED CHRIS
CUOMO BY NAME BUT WE DON’T BLAME
HER FOR THAT, YOU DON’T WANT TO
TANGLE WITH A MAN WHO DOESN’T
SQUAT THRUSTS WHILE EATING
LUNCH, YOU DON’T KNOW WHAT MIGHT
HAPPEN.
YOU DO WONDER ABOUT CHRIS CUOMO
AND YOU WORRY.
WE’LL HIS BROTHER HAD HIM
ARRESTED?
BACK IN MAY WE LEARNED THAT VERY
WELL COULD HAPPEN.
IN NEW YORK, NO ONE IS ABOVE
CORONA LAW.
>> I THINK IT’S DISRESPECTFUL OF
PEOPLE NOT TO WEAR MASKS.
THINK ABOUT IT, DO I THINK LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS SHOULD BE ENFORCING
IT AND THERE SHOULD BE
SANCTIONS?
YES.
BECAUSE IT IS A PUBLIC HEALTH
EMERGENCY, I THINK THERE SHOULD
BE A PENALTY BECAUSE YOU COULD
LITERALLY KILL SOMEONE.
YOU COULD LITERALLY KILL SOMEONE
BECAUSE YOU DIDN’T WANT TO WEAR
A MASK.
>> Tucker: YOU COULD LITERALLY
KILL SOMEONE.
THAT’S COMING FROM ANDREW CUOMO
WHO KNOWS SOMETHING ABOUT
LITERALLY KILLING PEOPLE IN
NEW YORK, YOU COULD SAY IT’S A
SPECIALTY.
WE DON’T EXPECT THEM TO SHIP HIS
BROTHER TO RIKERS, THE GOVERNOR
DIDN’T DO ANYTHING EARLIER THIS
MONTH WHEN WE SHOWED YOU THAT
PHOTOGRAPH OF CHRIS CUOMO
WITHOUT A MASK OUTSIDE AT A
CROWDED RESTAURANT ON
LONG ISLAND.
GOVERNOR CUOMO DIDN’T DO
ANYTHING EITHER WHEN HIS BROTHER
FAKED BEING IN QUARANTINE
EARLIER THIS YEAR AND SPENT THE
AFTERNOON HASSLING BICYCLISTS.
CHRIS CUOMO IS A GOOD PERSONS OF
THE IDEAS HE DESERVES A FOURTH
CHANCE, WATCH HIM MAKE HIS OWN
CASE.
>> WHILE MOST AMERICANS ARE
STAYING INSIDE OR SHOULD BE IF
THEY AREN’T OUT PROTESTING LIKE
FOOLS.
THEY AREN’T HAPPY ABOUT BEING
TOLD TO STAY HOME.
STAYING HOME SAVES LIVES.
THE REST OF US SHOULD BE STAYING
AT HOME FOR OUR MOTHERS AND THE
PEOPLE THAT WE LOVE AND TO KEEP
US FARTHER APART, IT WILL
ULTIMATELY BRING US CLOSER
TOGETHER.
NO MATTER WHERE THE VIRUS GOES,
THE WAY TO STOP IT WILL ALWAYS
BE THE SAME, OUR COLLECTIVE
CONSCIENTIOUS ACTIONS, STAYING
HOME.
>> Tucker: YOU’VE GOT A FEEL
FOR THE GUY, WE ARE MOCKING HIM
BUT LET’S TAKE THIS TO A MORE
HUMAN LEVEL.
IMAGINE BEING HIM.
BY DAY THERE HE IS GIVING YOU
MORE SERMONS ABOUT HOW YOU MUST
WEAR MASKS, BUT BY NIGHT, HE’S
WONDERING MASK LIST THROUGH HIS
OWN BUILDING, ENDANGERING HIS
NEIGHBORS AND IGNORING DEMANDS
THAT HE PUT ON A MASK.
IF CHRIS CUOMO MUST BE DEEPLY
UPSET WITH CHRIS CUOMO WHICH WE
ALREADY GUESSED FROM HIS